so you want to stop missing workouts due
to life events illness or lack of
motivation then make your workouts more
adaptable by making multiple versions of
each routine so for example you might
have a push day or chest day either way
this probably involves lots of equipment
you can only use at the gym what happens
on the days you can't get to the gym for
those days you need a home workout
version of that same routine so you
could swap things like the bench press
for dips using two chairs or you might
replace military press with Pike
push-ups perhaps not as optimal for your
specific goals but still very useful I
have versions of my workouts for the gym
the home the office and even fields or
the woods I also have versions for when
I'm very tired I kind of bare minimum
version of my routine account for every
scenario you can and you'll find you
stop missing workouts
bye for now